so recently uh zendaya and tom holland
and jacob talked about
uh
wanting to be part of spider-verse and
chris you responded on twitter by saying
call me or something along those lines
so i really need to know has phone calls
been made because jesus i want this
i don't know i know one's called me
i just got a call right now but i'd put
it straight forward to voicemail so from
zendaya it's possibly the day you know
she's all it could be
tom holland or it could be
um like a
local um political campaign asking for
money from like no it is uh you can't
tell it's this gentleman uh
potential his name is potential spam i
believe his name is yes yes i love that
guy
he's such a he's so
so corny tough last name but he's making
he really makes a go of it
okay i can i can see the avoidance i'll
just switch to something else
so look i'm obviously over the moon that
you guys are making two spider-verse
sequels and i'm just for fans what can
you tease about the movies um and i'm
assuming that well let me what can you
tease about the movies
um well i would say that
uh
as chris pointed out we only like to do
things that are hard
so we made it really hard on ourselves
um and we've made it pretty hard on
miles too
um and uh
i don't know can you i'm looking at
chris because i'm hoping
that the thing is he's more circumspect
than i am it is it is a
it is a
uh as phil said a very ambitious
uh
sequel because we didn't want to just
sort of do the same thing again and so
the idea that we would be going to
different dimensions really opened up an
opportunity um artistically
to have each world have its own art
style
and and to be able to push the folks at
image work to develop a way to have each
each dimension
feel like it was drawn by a different
artist's hand
and
seeing the development of that stuff is
um
is breathtaking and really it's the
reason that we keep doing it because
it's so hard uh to get it right
uh but it seems worse but the
opportunity is to like
yeah push animation in directions that
it hasn't gone yet and
that's what we're always trying to do
that's what chris tried to do with after
party it's what we tried to do with
mitchell's versus the machines and it's
sort of um
it's it's a problem if that's your
brand because it means you can't just go
like oh
i i do these paintings with dots and
lines i'll just do a bunch of those and
for the end of my career and and and uh
for us unfortunately we have to keep
changing it